[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to our installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing one of the most powerful
if not the most powerful witch in
history it's not one of the hogwarts
founders
it's not mcgonagall and it's not
bellatrix it's none other than morgana
le faye just recently i made a video on
merlin
the most powerful wizard in history so
it felt wrong not to make one on the
most powerful
witch morgana like merlin is a
pseudo-historical figure
and in many of the different versions of
folklore she exists in
she is actually merlin's nemesis and
once again
like merlin morgana existed in both
harry potter folklore
and our own folklore which makes her a
really interesting character to research
i love deep diving into these unknown or
beat powerful figures that exist in
folklore
there is so much mystique surrounding
them and it's really fun for me to peel
them back
layer by layer i'm going to start by
taking a look at the morgana
from our own folklore first of all
morgana isn't just known as morgana
in fact she is known under many aliases
most of which are close variations
of the name morgana however the alias
that most of us are probably most
accustomed to
is morgana le faye which means morgana
the fairy
she was a talented enchantress and like
merlin
was prevalent in both arthurian legend
and welsh poetry
the concept of morgana that we're most
familiar with first appears in writer
jeffrey of monmouth's work
entitled vita molini or the life of
merlin which was written in 1150.
evita molini was a latin poem written in
hexameter lines and it tells the story
of merlin's madness
his life as a wild man of the woods and
his prophecies and conversations
with his sister though popular vita
molini never matched the popularity of
monmouth's historia regum brittany
published in 1136 which was a
pseudo-historical account of british
history
that portrayed merlin in a bit of a
different light in monmouth's earliest
edition vita malini
morgana is referred to as morgen a name
which means
seabourn the name survived in middle
welsh as
morienne and the cognate form in old
irish
is the name of a shape-shifting female
saint
commonly associated with the sea
basically
morgana's name exists in about ten
thousand other formats
morgana's epithet le fay wasn't actually
introduced until much later
and was first introduced by writer
thomas mallory in the 15th century
it has been expressed that le faye can
be used interchangeably with
la fey and the character that mallory
discussed was based off of remnants of
supernatural females
from celtic mythology the earliest
account of morgana's character
appears in vita molini and morgana is
mentioned in reference to the isle of
apples
avalon where king arthur remember him
was being carried after being fatally
wounded in the battle of camelon
in vita molini and in many other works
morgana's character is portrayed in a
very morally
righteous light and her role was that of
a great healer
it is also in author crichen de trois's
work
that bolgana is first introduced as king
arthur's supernatural
elder sister a familial connection that
isn't consistent across all
tales pertaining to arthurian legend yes
that's right
morgana was the sister of king arthur
arthur pendragon
morgana is a tough pseudo-historical
figure to summarize
because across many pieces of literature
she has been reintroduced with
so many different names titles and
abilities
perhaps the most interesting thing about
morgana's character
however is her moral ambivalence and how
it evolved through folklore
early appearances of morgan do not
elaborate her character beyond her role
as a goddess
a fae a witch or a sorceress generally
benevolent and related to king arthur
as his magical savior and protector her
prominence increased over time
as did her moral ambivalence and in some
texts
there is an evolutionary transformation
of her to an antagonist
and while morgana is first introduced in
vita molini
the story that i know her character best
from once again circles back to the
story of king arthur
merlin and the knights of the round
table the story which has been subject
to
copious adaptations over the years tells
the tale of king arthur
his court his kingdom and his most
trustworthy men the knights of the round
table were a sub-order for the knights
of camelot
created by arthur pendragon and they
helped him fight dragons
evil-doers and all sorts of other
enemies in some adaptations of the story
merlin and the knights of camelot even
help arthur to combat
his own sister morgana pendragon in the
works of robert
de barron morgana is established as the
youngest daughter of arthur's mother
ukraine and her first husband gorhua
arthur who is the son of ukraine and
uther
is therefore morgan's half-brother and
just like that
her character had been completely
reintroduced where she was previously
painted as a morally righteous healer
with connection to the sea
and no familial relation to arthur
morgana suddenly became the
evil sister of arthur intent on
conquering camelot
this version of morgana who came to
prominence through the works of
thomas mallory was arthur's greatest
enemy constantly plotting to usurp his
throne
this version of morgana is not just evil
but pure evil
as her reasons for hating arthur and his
kingdom are never fully explained
she just seems to possess an extreme
antipathy towards the perfect goodness
which he symbolizes
so this evil antagonist morgana how
powerful is she
how much of a threat did she pose well
given the fact that this representation
of morgana
is said to rival merlin the most
powerful wizard of all time
i think that it's a safe bet to say that
morgana was the most powerful
witch of all time morgana is such an
enigmatic figure
her very existence has been adapted in
so many ways
and the fact that her morality
flip-flops from story to story
makes her particularly compelling not
only that but
her proposed levels of power give her a
certain allure
and we as human beings have a propensity
to be intrigued by those that exhibit
power and i think that that is perhaps
how morgana
a character from our own folklore ended
up in harry potter
we first hear of morgana le fay in the
harry potter universe
when ron mentions that he has about six
of her chocolate frog card
i've got morgana again and i've got
about six of her chocolate frog cards
generally feature
iconic witches and wizards of history so
the fact that she made the cuts
is a testament to her prominence as a
historical figure even in the harry
potter universe
her card makes it very clear that she
was a very powerful dark witch
and this directly sums up the version of
morgana the harry potter universe
adopted
we got the evil morgana not the morally
righteous one
provided that her card describes her as
a very powerful witch
i think that it's reasonable to assume
that morgana was extremely versed in the
dark arts
possessing knowledge of all of the dark
spells that we are accustomed to
and perhaps many more if she was the
adversary of merlin
the most powerful wizard to have ever
lived i imagine she must have had a few
tricks
up her sleeve what i find quite
interesting about morgana is that
despite being evil
she possessed immense knowledge of
powerful healing abilities
we generally associate healing and the
ability to heal
with those that are morally good or
righteous but
morgana contradicts this in fact now
that i think about it
grindelwald also contradicts this as he
too had an immense understanding
of healing charms could this perhaps
suggest a familial connection between
the two of them
maybe dumbledore is the descendant of
merlin and grindelwald is a descendant
of morgana
wouldn't that be interesting consistent
with some adaptations of folklore
the morgana of harry potter is related
to arthur she is his half-sister
she ruled over and was the queen of the
isle of avalon
which is now known as gastonbury she not
only possessed great knowledge of the
dark arts
and healing magic but is also said to
have been able to transform into a bird
at will
this suggests that morgana was perhaps
one of the earliest to become
an animagus morgana was a truly powerful
and enigmatic figure
and i think that what makes her most
interesting is the unpredictable duality
of her nature exhibiting the potential
for both good and evil
depending on the story and that's it for
this video
did you guys know about morgana already
if so
what did you know about her it was fun
to make this video so let me know if
there are
any other relatively unknown or alluring
characters that you want me to explore
until next time you're a wizard harry
you